good morning everyone we now we now open
the hearing of for the commission to
study State controlled sales of cannabis
and cannabis
products representative Hunt is back
from his
vacation well and as good as ever would
you would you do the honor of leading Us
in the
pledge
plge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
all chair I move the minutes as written
and presented so you like to make a
motion yes I move the minutes as written
and presented is there a
second has been seconded any
discussion see none all those in favor
opposed motion
passes uh before we begin I think we're
going to do the majority of today we're
going to just make it kind of like the
work session we'll allow some public
comment as well as we go but I do know
that we have
um the New Hampshire coalation for
responsible canvas legislations here uh
I they told me that there they like two
minutes of time so we'll
see two yeah so they're going to talk
about distribution and we'll we'll allow
that uh we'll recognize them to speak
right
now thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee um two minutes go um I'm arri
Pollock I'm with the law firm of
Gallagher cian and garell here in
conquered uh one of our clients New
Hampshire Coalition for responsible
cannabis legisl
uh is has been following this
conversation this commission's work
they're comprised of a group of large
beer and beverage distributors now
serving most of New Hampshire uh they
have modern state-of-the-art warehousing
professional drivers of trucking Fleet
Insurance the ability to track inventory
tax product uh make deliveries they know
what they're doing uh they contract with
multiple manufacturers they move
varieties of products for for big makers
if new Hampshire is going to legalize
recreational Cannabis then many of the
same controlled substance issues uh and
priorities that now affect beer and
alcohol distribution will certainly come
to the surface in the regulation and
transportation of cannabis in that
Marketplace in order to prioritize
safety product tracking access security
all the things that are valued in the
three tier alcohol model um we would
suggest that the Mission consider a
definition of cannabis distributor which
if authorized would allow a a licensed
distributor to move product from
multiple cultivators to and between
multiple cannabis establishments this
would not deprive those who are
cultivating moving their own and to
their own centers and vertically
integrated from being a cannabis
transporter as that definition is now in
your work work product but it would add
an additional uh option for those who
don't want to transport their own and
wish to Outsource those Services we've
got a memo uh that um was on the
distribution table last time but I have
additional copies that I'll send around
with suggestions for that definition if
I've gone slightly be Beyond two minutes
apologies thank
you
does anyone have any
questions link so again your your ideas
that we'll have um as we form these
public private Partnerships this will be
the private side of the partnership that
would allow for um warehousing a product
and then distribution so at five o'clock
at night when somebody might run out of
product they could have a phone number
to call and be able to get product
delivered to them in a manner which
similar you do now for beer and those
kind of things exactly correct thank
you
is is there any anyone on have any
comment on this you know I think this
allows more
flexibility is the way I kind of look at
it I know does liquor have
any U Mr chair just a quick comment uh I
think this is a relevant option that we
should certainly look at in the
legislation it's uh I I think it it
doesn't take away from the way it's
written now just gives us another option
for uh the folks that will be in the
business either on the manufacturing
side or the retail side so I think it's
you right thank you for your testimony I
I I think this you
know maybe incorporating this memorandum
into you know it's more than one section
but does anyone have any objection with
that I think it's a wonderful idea yeah
it's not it's not a formal motion but
it's like when we put together what we
hope to be a bill proposed bill would um
I think it's relevant to make sure we
have this in there so we'll put that in
there all right so I think we were last
talking thank
you we were we were last had to do with
um we call it the sanctuary policy and
the
violation uh section the public use so I
think there was page we starting page
that's the uh I I call it the sanctuary
Paul that's just what it is we've seen
language like that in other other
formats given some time for this to go
back and forth um I know we had a very
healthy conversation about it last week
my understanding that if this language
stays in there this might fall
apart so I have my own opinion on it
but
if we don't compromise then we're not
going to have anything right I I
recommend Mr say we strike the language
so I may not necessarily agree with some
of the some of the debate the direction
we're going but I think if we take if we
if we leave that in there I'm not sure
we're we're spinning our tires and mud
on everything else so I I would
recommend we take that out and I would
say though Chief and I I I understand if
there ever is an operation where the
fed's in local law enforcer working
together I just would pray that liquor
is also a priz at the situation as it's
unfolding perfectly
in as as it's done now with alcohol
thank you Mr chair no there there would
be no change in the coordination with
liquor with respect to those laws for
which liquor has the authority to
enforce as we do now so there would be
no change and I and I concur with the
proposal to redact the U I concur with
the proposal to redact the language
simply because as we discussed last time
uh it presents significant uh
prohibition to proper coordination of
Public Safety um in every community in
in New Hampshire I I I understand I I'm
still saying I prefer to leave it in but
at the same
time I'm I'm not it's not going to work
we're
striking what I would say is is uh we
have a consensus on that one way or
another
I'm for striking who's if you're for
hand
okay what's
gone yeah I was allumed on that
one next is the uh if you go to page
seven lines one through five that is the
public use provision uh that applies to
vaping
and
smoking I know my friend to my left
Senator Lang wanted that to be a
misdemeanor a Class B misdemeanor know
our friends from the
ACLU do not not appreciate that Senator
Whitley's not here she was um also
opposed to
that um where are we on that today any
more thought
any
Frank so if we look at our neighbors um
in Maine it is I believe just a $100
fine in Mass it's a $100 fine but in
Vermont it's much more uh in line with
what I think the compromise sounded like
last time which is a graduated fine
system so it is 100 for the First
Defense second up to Second 200 for the
second offense and not more than 500 for
third and subsequent I think that's a
fair balance between the two positions
um particularly because there's zero
evidence that criminalizing is actually
a deterrent in this respect um and so
all we're doing is funneling more people
to the Cal legal system which we know
has collateral harms but respectfully
those first of all in Old Orchard Beach
I can tell you they're not enforcing it
very well and in Massachusetts places
I've been
to uh it's not being enforced very well
so those violation I mean if it's not if
the Fine's not a deterrent then what are
we even doing well I think there's a
difference between the fine not being a
deterrent and people not enforcing the
law so if folks want to enforce that I
mean if people aren't enforcing we can't
help that but if we have a place that
gives them tool essentially parallel to
that of a parking but that's also how we
keep our road safe we have fines in
terms of speeding that keeps I mean
that's that's how we run safety in
multiple aspects of our society you're
right but if you keep speeding you're
going to lose your driver's license what
do you lose here the I mean I'm just
saying I get it but but I think it's I
mean it's a problem because it's our
two-tier system of people with wealth
can afford these fines and people
without can't um but it is it is how we
we deal with lots of issues in our we
can afford to buy the marijuana I I'm
not hoping that they bought it legally
from
a retail store and then they go out of
their way this is not something you're
going to violate accidentally all right
you may not know the speed limit you may
whatever but this you have to go out of
your way to violate
so so just understand Colorado uh public
consumption is a misdemeanor punishable
by fing up to $100 Andor 15 days in jail
Illinois public consumption is marijuana
is a misdemeanor punishable by a fine of
up to $500 in Michigan uh it's a
misdemeanor punishable by a fine of $500
Andor 90 days in jail up to 90 days in
jail so I think we're trying to strike a
reasonable compromise here and I'd be
okay with moving the first offense down
to a violation level offense but a
second offense which changes the entire
you know first offense a person may not
know it's illegal to smoke in public
it's legal they know it's legal so
therefore they may not realize they
can't smoke it in public the cigarettes
are smoked in public and so we give them
a up to a $500 fine allows it a judge to
be able to offer classes or alternative
models um if he wants to on that first
offense but the fine could be up to 00
$500 but on a second offense the mental
state changes from I didn't know to you
knowingly know it is and you've chosen
not to follow the law so it's an act of
knowing it's not an act of I didn't know
and so from that reason I wanted I think
we should have an enhanced penalty
because the person is is acting it
absolutely contrary to the Hampshire law
and is just thumbing their nose at the
court after they've been after they've
been already fined once for this so I
want to I'd like to see uh uh it be a
misdemeanor and and um and be I I don't
know we want to stick to a b or I'd
prefer an a misdemeanor with up to a
$2,000 Fine Again the judge can assess
whether jail time because if it's a
third and fourth offense the judge may
want in increase that enhanced penalty
and allow for jail time because this
guy's just not following the law and
putting other citizens um rights if you
will to aside right we've said that it
we don't want public consumption they're
just ignoring it we made a public policy
of that for our citizens and they're
ignoring it so I'd like to see it stay
an a misdemeanor on a second and
subsequent offense and allow discretion
to the
judge but I'm willing to go down to a
violation on a first
offense thank you Mr chair with all due
respect this uh this is New Hampshire
this isn't Maine or Mac CH its and both
of their their systems have completely
failed their populations and are are
crumbling their states um if if if we
were
to ignorantly leave this as a $100 fine
no municipality would be enforcing that
law because they would be losing money
enforcing that law I I agree with the
senator we we need to have even stronger
monetary um penalties for for public
smoking we don't want public smoking and
it absolutely does infringe on other
people's rights not to do drugs right
you know we want to be able to breathe
in public that's like a god-given right
I know some people don't like that word
but it is a god-given right so and and
with all due respect there there was no
compromise that there is no compromise
um we do need the Class B misdemeanor we
do need strong penalties so that we can
law one thing we need to consider is if
a police officer say in conquered give
somebody a violation ticket
for or uh smoking in public say uh three
months later the person's in Manchester
uh he that person's smoking in public a
Manchester police officer cites them at
this time there's no way the way the
system is is set up and correct me if
I'm wrong uh Chief uh unless that's a
state summons we nobody will ever know
whether or not this is a first or second
fence or third or fourth so and plus
when also have to consider that when you
when you stop somebody from a violation
you still need to seize the marijuana it
still needs to be uh and it also needs
to be tested as well so I would keep
that in mind and I just go back to and I
understand the I understand the concept
and I I I don't disagree with you on a
lot of it but we just decriminalized Mar
we just decriminalized marijuana now
we're talking about legalizing it so now
it to me it just doesn't match up where
the substance itself is legal
but but we are going to uh make it a
crime if you're smoking it in public we
with alcohol we we don't do that and I
understand in the reason I'm I'm I'd be
agreeable to or amendable if it has to
go that way to a Class B misdemeanor
is I understand the the the whole
concept about secondhand smoke and what
it can that you can actually have
marijuana in your system from the
secondhand smoke just to
clarify would you be are you suggesting
the first offense be a violation offense
but the second offense would be a class
if we're going to go if it's if we're
going to go to it a step up but so
second offense would be a Class B
misdemeanor
yeah as as opposed to a class A and and
and just for everyone knows the
difference between the two a Class B
misdemeanor you cannot go to you would
not be sentenced to jail I mean you are
if you're violating like your pre-trial
conditions or if you're violating
probation that can but that's different
but for that offense in of itself you
would not be sentenced to a jail
sentence okay that's a question AG yeah
yeah you can ask so a question for the
AG if we didn't CL specify a or B and
just said misdem meter does that leave
it to the discretion of the prosecutor
to charge either
way misdem meter a the answer is yes
answer so you'd have to provide notice
if you're going to proceed with the the
a uh so if you're if you're not defining
anything then the presumption would be a
b if you're providing notice of those
enhanced penalties then you could move
it to an A so I guess Mr chair given
that that scenario I would I would agree
with a violation on the first and just a
word misdemeanor for the second and then
if we have somebody who is you know
second offense they may again give them
the benefit of the doubt but a third
offense they could charge it as an a if
they want to if that if that or fifth
they want to and then for allowing even
further enhanced penals but if we just
change it to a violation at the first
level we don't even have to put a fine
because we know what the violations for
misdemeanors are they're already in
statute it's an up to language and the
same with a misdemeanor there's an up to
language in statute already so we can
just change to it's it's a violation
with no fine set and it's a misdemeanor
on a subsequent
fence um thank you um you know I think
it's important that I think we all agree
that smoking in public is not a good
thing and I think we all are trying to
figure out how to mitigate and stop that
from happening I think from our
perspective it's that's not the question
the question is what is effective and I
think the research is quite clear that
criminalizing conduct like this is not
effective and in fact it puts hurdles in
front of people so if you're giving
people even a be misdemeanor they're
going to have a criminal record would
makes it harder to get employment it
makes it harder to get housing things
that we know from research you know um
increase recidivism rates and so I think
it would be problematic for us to kind
of put those additional hurdles in front
of people if we're trying to stop people
from smoking in public and the research
doesn't show that that would actually be
effective but the research does show
that it would make it harder and create
collateral harms from idual why would we
go that route um and I think that's
that's a core part of our concern here
so you know we all agree smoking in
public is bad but let's figure out a way
to do that that's effective and
minimizes harm how many times would
someone have to be found responsible for
a violation before you would be
comfortable with it being a Class B MISD
I mean five 10 I mean there it does
reach a point
where people are just going to pay the
fine and do what they want I think it's
the same with smoking cigarettes in
public which have tremendous secondhand
consequences you know there's I don't
know what that magic number is but
criminalizing we know is not effective
and so I think it's it's I guess the
premise I think I have concerns with
because that premise assumes that at
some point it becomes effective I've
never seen research to show that it does
become effective I'm asking though for
the purposes of this because the number
one complaint I hear about any
recreational policy in the other states
and this is just talking to people on
the people in the communities is the
public use issue that's what bothers a
lot of people that's what bothers me and
can we stop it will people still violate
the you can criminalize there's class A
felonies out there people violate the
Wason you're right it doesn't deter
people from doing horrible things all
right this violent crimes all I can go
on and on I'm just asking how many times
does someone have to violate this
provision intentionally smoke or vape
cannabis in a public place before you're
comfortable and say all right now we can
do a class be Mr it could be a High
number I'm just trying to say at some
point is it really out of line to
elevate the offense I know there was a
suggestion on the second offense maybe
the third offense maybe the fourth but
again you're whoever's getting in
trouble for this they're intentionally
violating law they're not they're not
even trying to comply with they're going
well out of their way so I'm just asking
what what's the what's the common ground
here I think we also have to realize
like in a state like New Hampshire where
we have urban and rural you know this is
going to be applied quite differently in
different places where people who live
in dense raw areas have less opportunity
to smoke potentially in their I mean so
there's there's not equal footing in our
state on this issue um right off the bat
and so I don't know that there's a magic
number I because I don't know where the
evidence shows that there is a magic
number Our concern is that criminalizing
this type of conduct is
counterproductive to Public Safety um
it's not a deterrent and so I don't see
a magic number really appearing if if
those are the Baseline
facts I
mean not saying any numbers right M
asking five on the fifth offense can we
mrir I don't I'm sure others have the
answer
no Chief thank you Mr chair well with
due resp with all due respect to my
commission colleague consequences do
affect public Behavior Uh that is the
reason why we have a system of laws in
the country with
penalties and in this case the
discussion now centers on what is the
necessary consequence deter people from
smoking cannabis in public which we all
take judicial notice of that in places
uh near us uh the penalties have been
ineffective totally ineffective in
inhibiting that practice so in this case
um well it
is humankind nature to not want to
criminalize on the alternative side uh
if we were to enact a panel and fine uh
significant with consequences
significant enough so that the general
public both residents and visitors would
take notice that it is not a wise idea
and a costly idea and the analogy
frankly ladies and gentlemen would be uh
our current endemic of speeding in the
state of New Hampshire uh where the
fineing fee schedule is totally uh
ineffective in detering speeding so in
this case the proposal that I would uh
recommend is that we start with a
mandatory minimum where the judge cannot
reduce it down to a Happy Meal somewhere
at the $150 to $250 range a minimum not
uh not less than um and then up to $500
and then graduated into a Class B
misdemeanor for subsequent
offenses uh with a mandatory minimum of
not less than
uh it sends the clear message that the
state is serious about detering this
kind of behavior uh and it is a bit
costly uh which does uh tend to create
uh the consequence inhibition in human
behavior human behavior does pay
attention to consequences we've seen
that every place else in the country for
anyone who hasn't spoke on this issue
yet does anyone else have any comment as
they watch four of us or five of us
debate amongst ourselves and I feel like
you know we're all we're all taking on
Frank by ourselves you know what's
him I I would actually like to know if
there's a single policy that he can
recommend that has actually succeeded in
stopping people from smoking publicly in
states that don't want public smoking a
single
policy I mean I think that's the
research that we need to focus on and I
think part I mean part of the reason we
have problems with our criminal legal
system in the first place is because
we've put criminal laws into place
without any evidence that they're
effective that's led to mass I mean we
have 5% of the world's population 25% of
the world's incarcerated population
because we didn't do research on the
front end and put into law you know put
into policy laws that are actually
counterproductive and we're starting to
repeal those laws across the country so
I think it's important that we on the
front end before you create criminal
laws and take away people's Liberty
figure out ways that is this effective
and if the answer is yes then that's
potentially appropriate if the answer is
no if there's no research we we
shouldn't do that we shouldn't you know
the the the gut check shouldn't be
criminalized the gut check should be
what is effective and go from
there any comment any so what you're
saying is you have no no policy that
succeeds
well listen it you can make this a class
a felony people are still going to
violate the law so I don't think that
that making it a harsh penalty is going
to stop it in its entirety rips him H
welcome back yeah I I'm I'm a big
believer of kiss and um and so I would
say we should model what after the
Smoking law is because that way the the
the officer won't get into you know whe
whether whether were smoking marijuana
or smoking C whatever it is you smoking
we have you know do you're not allow to
smoke in public and keep it simple and
and uh uh if if if you really that in
terms of you know getting making some
tears and making like this I I just
don't know any of those things were
effective because most people just were
going to smoke I mean when you're out in
the middle of the woods and nobody's
around you and you were smoking and then
all of a sudden just happened to be a
fishing game guy walk by you know and oh
my God versus you know walking down the
Main Street where uh to a concert and
everybody in his brother is smoking and
the LA is not going to enforce it there
because there's too many people to
enforce it against so it just keep it
simple I I will say the putting in line
with tobacco would stall this in the in
the
Senate uh okay well whatever me you
would be allowed to smoke it right out
front of the state house and that that
was a deal break that's still a $100
fine isn't it Mr chair if I can propose
some language and just see if how we
take a raise of hands to see who would
support that maybe we can move past this
piece um I understand some people aren't
going to support the recommendation but
to see if we get a majority of the
committee to say yes so the
recommendation is that no person shall
smoke or vaporized can abis in an area
accessible to any public any person who
violates this section shall be guilty of
a violation and shall forfeit the
Cannabis and cannabis products for the
first offense on a subsequent offense it
shall be a misdemeanor um a subsequent
offense within three years shall be a
misdemeanor period just let's not set
fines let's not set uh limitations it
makes it simple it's a violation it's a
misdemeanor uh because we've heard from
the AG that a misdemeanor can go either
A or B depending on what the prosecutor
wants to bring based on history it
allows for some flexibility and
discretion um it doesn't it allows a
judge to be able to wave fines and allow
a class if they want um instead of
setting a prescriptive uh U value in a a
violation so something as simple as that
to John to John's point the
representative Hunts Point it's a kiss
symbol a kiss principle violation on
first offense misdemeanor on second
offense within three years and let the
let it let it roll out from there sink
can I make a a comment maybe first first
offense violation second offense Class B
misia third offense no that starts
violating John's kiss principle right we
just say misdemeanor it allows for
prosecutorial discretion um based on the
number of offenses again if this guy's
the fifth offense I may want to charge
as a be misdemeanor for the second and
third offense but by the fourth offense
I'm done with this guy and I want to
charge I guess I I will say because I
told you before I have nothing about
this criminal stuff because I don't but
the one thing I do know is that um if
you just say muner that automatically
defaults to a be no it defaults to a
because it's the assumption that when we
didn't have a
b oh we it anything that was just said
mror that was automatically in a then B
creates a new category but I'm just
saying is that that my understanding
from my short time here in the house is
that uh if you don't say it it's on it's
assumed it's an a because it's an old
statute no no um represent what the
represent from
the AG's office to um offer comment yeah
RSA
6259 Roman numeral 4 um C addresses the
the classification of misdemeanors uh if
it's specified in law then that holds so
if it's a Class B or Class A then that
designation holds if it's undesignated
uh then the the default would be for a
class B unless there are three
circumstances where it could be um
elevated so for example if it's a threat
of violence then uh that would be a
Class A if it's unspecified or if a a um
prosecutor files a notice of intent to
seek the enhance penalties under C2 uh
and filing the notice of intent form
then that would elevate it from a Class
B to a class
A so again we can I just ask for a show
a hands and see who would support kind
have a question uh to the does it propos
proposal that you just put up not
contain a fine it it leaves sorry it
would leave the current fine schedule
for a violation which is up to $1,000
right that's what a that's what is a
violation level offense if I remember
right and a be a misdemeanor has a
violation uh fine up to $2,000 or let
let me so I I think if I remember right
those are the I'm not sure about a B
misdemeanor what the high is a thousand
again still
12,200 so again would l for a maximum
fine up to those levels but doesn't
designate A Fine Again leaving it to um
the aggravating mitigating circumstances
of an individual offense the judge could
certify well let me make u a prediction
based on my 45 years of experience in
law enforcement you will never get to a
Class B misdemeanor because the vast
majority of police officers under those
conditions under the circumstances that
you just described will make the person
and stop throw it away or take
possession of it and that'll be the end
of it you won't never get to the second
offense in the real world that may in
the real world that's what will happen
ladies and gentlemen no I understand
that that that's but that's also keep in
mind
that's that's and and by the way that
will not deter at all one thing that we
in if if you guys are really serious
about not having public smoking you know
that this proposal is a joke but
couldn't they but couldn't descriptive
or wrong if they if a person let's say
it could be their second offense I mean
they can still be charged or issued the
violation is the first that's up you
won't get there the practical
application in in humanity is is that
most police officers given the legality
of the substance and the and the
relative low uh and processing nature
and cost as as the good representative
indicated exercising the system is a
burden to the taxpayer at this point and
without any deterrent
effect so uh better to have a deterrent
effect or have nothing at all because at
the end of the day you need to make
sense of what you're doing and that's
the practical application that I'm
predicting here both so without a fine
uh it's not going to go anywhere it's
going to get end up being dumped and
that's the end of the day you won't
never get to a class feed Mr Mayor but I
think the first I think what Senator
Lang was suggesting was the first
offense could be up to a, fund for the
violation it could be up to $1,000 fine
but uh but no less than you want less
than language but there needs to be a
threshold again because people simply
won't know what they're facing it could
be a $5 fine it could be a $10 fine the
judge has wide latitude so under that
under that scenario maybe no less than
100 bucks if smoking's 100 every sign
they're not the same thing with all due
respect say any smoken device it'll be a
$100 F Well maybe maybe we do just so we
can get a motion voted on here or maybe
we do no less than 100 but up to a th000
some offenses are more egregious than
others and this is as we discussed in
the last meeting for the benefit of
those that were here there was I think
uh a significant discussion regarding
the differentiation between smoking
cannabis in public and the ill effects
that could uh ascribe to that from
people nearby versus smoking otherwise
well what's do this what's what's vote
on what nothing's final by the way
there's still going to be this still has
to be introduced legisl still has to be
public hearings on that I'm just
we got a lot of pages to go but why
don't we just take for Senator Lang's
proposal who's in favor that please
hand sure to reread it just it would
just say that any person who violates a
section shall be guilty of a violation
on first offense and shall forfeit all
cannabis and products um and on a second
offense be guilty of a misdemeanor
subject to Forfeit of uh cannabis
products if the offense occurs the
second offense occurs within three years
so again allows I mean I'd be we weren't
close by the way so we W even close so
that's so if the sticking point is a
minimum threshold I don't know what
everybody's sticking point is how about
this because we don't have a consensus
uh as it's proposed $500 fine is that
what people that is that is that the
consensus that's even wor if you if you
the original Lang in there who supports
hand well these guys
want want enfor
so remember this is still going to go
through committees in multiple Chambers
here right but I'm just trying to and
clearly smoking cigarettes doesn't cost
my security yeah I'm not compar I don't
I agree with you tobacco and games are
different human nature is if you want to
avoid folks getting J Amed with a
misdemeanor and being put in the
criminal system then started off with
something that is consequential
sufficiently consequential to alert them
what Chief what I'm going to do I'm
going to leave the language that's in
the the the rough draft as it is and
when that goes through the when there's
public hearings in the house and Sen
that's going to be fought over there at
this point we don't have a consensus on
anything we don't so you know I don't I
certainly don't want to strike the
language so we're going to leave it as
it is for now and I I think in the
public hearings we'll debate that more
if we want to cover that issue again if
we have time we will but I think we got
to move on so because we have another
very animated uh conversation have on
page seven lines 5 to 25 that's
uh it creates a lot of problems that
we're going to have to deal with now so
um as it's
written does anyone have any issues with
the language as it's written
abut FL is yours represent Gil this is
this is not a strong enough deterrent
with the amount of traffic fatalities
that we're experiencing on our roads the
highest number of motorcycle fatalities
we've had in 20
years $150 fine that's like a clown
show and we also need some language for
for handsfree use of vaporizing so you
on are you on number line
15 16 16 yeah sorry this Roman numeral
two
Senator I think he's on R Minal three
sorry I I assumed that we were just
going to be talking about this as a
whole bu bang so is everybody okay with
section one as it's
written everybody okay with section two
is
written great now we're on three and the
penalty portion of it is representative
kill's issue yeah I prefer that to be
say misdemeanor
not um violation so that mean and if you
section I also think it needs to include
language about the hands-free use of
these stupid vaporizer pens I mean let's
be honest when people are driving down
the road using them they're not driving
for the handsfree issue you just raised
we can make that its own Roman numeral
so perhaps at the next meeting maybe
we'll have a potential Roman numeral six
if you can put something together for us
to to look at but I think that
that's um that's something obviously
worth
discussing uh Senator the the question
here from uh Public Safety is where uh
in these sections if this is the correct
section should we have a discussion with
respect to establishing a prima fascia
limit for an
operator with a certain amount of th
Delta 9 THC per nanogram per milliliter
of blood that's consistent with some of
the other states many of the other
states that are
legalized Dr shaking her head can you
offer us some I see I know there's
different yeah I I mean I don't know
what the cut offs are that I I'm sure
the chief does but I I certainly think
you know if people are driving in talk
toxicated and putting the rest of us all
at risk there should be some cut off
that's um that is um I mean that that
the police have to work off of I know
that like in Seattle this like my
friends in the police force there where
I grew up had a really you know strong
learning curve of saying like clearly
they're intoxicated but we we don't know
how to enforce this we need to make it
enforcable so let's just say that the
limit was to is integrant am I saying
that correctly the the range that we see
in States range from two nanograms per
milliliter up to seven um nanograms per
milliliters uh one state is actually at
zero but here's here's the issue it's
it's not and it should not be
interpreted the same way as a breath
test is uh and here's the reason why a
breath test we've come to the scientific
conclusion that 0.008 uh is presumptive
limit scientifically for impairment for
operation of a motor vehicle Uh current
ly there is no scientific evidence with
respect to intoxication by cannabis the
states that have set a limit have said
so knowingly and arbitrarily to induce
their population that now has legalize
cannabis to not drive right with while
using cannabis or under the influence of
cannabis so uh this would be a prima
fascia uh limit which means that it
would only establish along with other
evidence produced by a law enforcement
officer a level of intoxication but it
at least allows the officer bring
legitimate charges before the judge and
produce other evidence now can I ask one
question yeah so I understand the
various this is a ballpark it's a
question for Dr Younger if let's just
say it was five nags am I saying that
correctly nagr familiar and so if I if
it's it's just say the it's the per se
five how much cannabis is someone we
just use my someone 215 pounds how much
do I have to have to register I guess
well that's that's The $64,000 Question
that science has yet to come to a
conclusion because it the body
metabolizes THC differently in your
fatty tissue uh based on your body
composition uh the states that have said
I want to get into that yeah
right I I I think that uh we can take
traditional notice of your of your
physique so I I have no idea what that
limit would be for you or anyone else in
the room but again we work off of what
other states have done uh here in the
state of New Hampshire I can tell you
with two fatals in my community
back-to-back fatals two separate fatals
with significant quantities uh Delta
nthc in their bloodstream we could not
get a conviction neither the County
Attorney nor the Attorney General's
office so we desperately need desper
someone let's say our our friends at the
AG's office want issue an advisory on
this how could we advise someone to
comply with the law if we have no idea
like someone might be violating even
knowing they violing the smoking in
public that person definitely knows what
they're doing and just doesn't care this
one you could perceivably be over the
two the five the seven whatever it is
but I'm not sure how much a person's
using to get to that five and seven it's
very on body and all
thatly it's a same no I'm not I'm not
qualified to be able to make that
statement is
anyone but at but at the end of the day
no one is because the science and
research is not well established in this
regard recognize that the states that
have set those limits have done so
knowingly to induce their population not
to drive while
using and again it's primeasia it's not
0.08 um if helpful and I think this this
is coming from the Michigan impaired
driver safety commission um and they
actually are recommending now against
the threshold of um of a Delta 9 THD
bodily content and instead recommend the
use of roadside sobriety tests to
determine whether someone's impared or
not and so and I know we have Revenue in
here in the current version to ensure
that we have the ability to kind of get
officers and others tested up on
roadside impairment for marijuana that
roadside soety test you just referenced
in Michigan is that being accepted by
the courts in Michigan because one thing
it sounds great to send law enforcement
to get trained on a field sobriety test
but it needs to be accepted by the court
as to our evidence if it's not going to
be accepted by the court it's a waste of
time and resources in mind and that's
what happened in
Massachusetts so do Dr
I I would be happy to look at the
medical literature because I I I hear
what you're saying about how can it be
like how can we not violate the law if
it's legal and we don't know how much
that is um but how long does the average
person need to have not consumed can
cannabis in order to be adherent to this
law I mean I I'm happy to look to see
what what that looks like in the medical
literature if you don't mind doing that
because I think the it's one thing to
have number there it's nothing we don't
people violating law without even
realizing they're doing it right in from
a public safety perspective you know we
have you know it's easy with alcohol but
at least we know people know what the
legal limit is but I think getting some
information from the dark might help us
pin down a number whether it's two five
seven whatever well in in the two cases
in the two fatalities single car crashes
right the evidence was in one case the
operator of the vehicle was tested as a
result of the Fatal and had 54 nanograms
for mill
of can of THC in in their blood at the
time of the crash the second operator
had 34 nanograms fromer in their blood
at the time of the crash and in neither
case neither case could neither the
Attorney General's office who adopted
one case nor could the county attorney
in the other case obtain a conviction
for impairment no I understand that I'm
just trying to when we make a
recommendation we got to pick a me a
measurement and I'm we're just trying to
lock down what it takes to get to that
measure we can do that right now with
certainty alol I understand we we're not
going to have an exact amount the
ballparking in but at least having some
idea what the law is going to be so
people aren't violing left and right by
accident I I I take what you what you
saying very serious because 54
sounds you know through the roof here I
get it so why don't we wait for Dr Young
to get us some information on that I can
I use shorts so again I I wanted to be
clear we're not talking about DUI in a
section right this is strictly anybody
who smokes a joint in a car is going to
be convicted all you have to do is prove
that it's marijuana and you saw him
smoking it and that's the conviction
this isn't about levels we don't have a
265 uh a statute yet in I don't know if
it's later on in this bill but that's
not what we're discussing right here so
you don't need to prove that it's even
in their system you need to prove that I
saw him smoking this I tested this and
this is marijuana you're convicted of
the section um I think we I think we
should take a look at somewhere the bill
where we look at 265a which is the DUI
statutes and whether we set a prim
acious standard under the 265 statutes
like we have uh 0.08 and 01 that's what
we're gonna we're going to do so I think
but but I'm just I just want to move the
conversation along so we're not talking
about that right here right now we're
just strictly talking about smoking in a
car um that's moving and and whether or
not that's leg paragraph three I I would
prefer that to be a misdemeanor because
it's basically you're using it while
operating vehicle all right you can
strike the fine section lost lights up
to 68 for the first offense one year for
the second any I'm fine with that any
objection to
that that I mean literally that's when
you're using it while driving like just
smoking and driving as we so um all
right just one to Mo
that you like we and we'll come we'll
come back to that I think at the next
meeting I think get good Dr does any
information you get if if it even exist
and anyone listening if you have any
information on that so please help us
out next meting you're striking not to
exceed $150 and replacing that with Mr
meter it yeah you don't need to have the
fine section because that's already in
other other round yeah because because
we don't want we don't want a limitation
on fine we we want to hold these people
accountable for putting every citizen in
the state at risk the M demeanor there's
already a statutory finding in general
so we don't have to add to it
um otherwise we all that section we all
go
with okay so on then now same SE uh same
page 26 to 38 if you look at ran num 1
29 to 33 that has to do with that's
basically cut and pasting precedence I
don't think we need to do that in
statute so we can strike that if if the
scent of alcohol is not in of itself
probably CA the search same thing with
the Canabis it's legal same thing if
it's been if it's been decriminalized
you can't there's no criminal offense to
search so that language is is repetitive
I'm always hesitant to cut and paste a
supreme court holding
and putting it into an RSA because every
word matters and that's how things get a
little mixed up so I I would say we can
strike that and rely on the existing
presence does the AG's office have any
comment on
that no additional comment on
that so we striking it I think that
whole section can just come out I
agree so lines 27 to 38 oh it doesn't
change the exist the law either way CH
yes so I I'm sorry we need to go back to
line
23 um and this I think this was meant to
say that you can't be charged with both
smoking in the car as well as DUI except
it's referencing the wrong statute um
265 A1 is
definitions I don't think you're
violating a definition statute I think
you we have 265 A2 or three which is DUI
or aggravated DWI that that that's
correct Senator that that should
probably go if you're
changing I agree we should be we should
be getting rid of that we should be
holding these people accountable for
putting everything section five all
together so Roman numero 5 is is
Senator invading your your
desk
so when it comes to
um we're now on the enforcement
s if you're on Roman numer one Senator
um I would propose that uh at line 40 it
would be the New Hampshire Liquor
Commission they'll have the primary
clear technically we defined Commission
in in the definition section right so
when we're referencing commission it
specifically references New Hampshire
Liquor
Commission we do say that on page four
line 34 commission shall mean the New
Hampshire Liquor
Commission
right
and I think in paragraph two I believe
we heard some testimony that there was
likely to be a distinction between
liquor and cannabis
investigators where it shows Liquor on
uh Roman numeral 2 line two perhaps
consideration change at the Cannabis
investigators that's what the commission
intends to do separate the two can I ask
uh is there what's the I suppose
rational are having separate
investigators for cannabis versus liquor
I understand you know internally one may
someone can kind of specialize more in
One Direction or the other but I guess
there I mean does it make sense for us
to legislate the
distinction is or is that necessary for
us I I wouldn't think so I I don't think
we have to legislate the distinction I
understand internally they may choose to
operate that way but maybe an
investigator is an investigator and they
can well if they're all liquor
investigators and they also investigate
cannabis that's fine um but I think that
uh you don't want to create a defense uh
for someone who's investigated by a um a
a liquor uh person yet and yet they make
the distinction later on well I think
the what I'm saying is essentially any
liquor investigator would also be a
cannabis investig now internally they
may have some if that's what they want
to do then then the language is fine
some investigators may have a directive
that they're they're focus on this yeah
as opposed to that but that's an
internal operation am I let's just
strike the word liquor just is
out yeah shello investigators and leave
it
open yes all right so but it doesn't
have to say liquor
investigators because that's what
they're called say investigator but if
it's
investigators aren't they called liquor
investigators throughout other rsas so
so we have to keep that consistency I'm
saying if you look at other sections
it's going to say liquor investigators
we got to keep the same
language even though they're doing more
than that the title is the title but
it's not this we're not it's going to be
called The Liquor Commission still even
though they also
it's also going to involve cannabis
yeah
P we
did the other comment the Chiefs would
make uh this would be uh Roman numeral
two I think one two three four four
lines down in that paragraph where where
it says with or independently of
officers with count counties or towns uh
we would just ask that or independently
of be stricken uh it should be a
Cooperative effort or at least
notification there with the
municipalities the counties and or and
and even in those areas where the state
police or the primary Authority should
should be properly coordinated is there
similar language right now for for
liquor like if it's if it's a liquor
Enforcement issue I I don't know what
that language is Senator I because I I I
want to say that this
is so I I I I appreciate what you're
saying I'm I'm just saying that
consistently for if it's just when it
this language when it's used somewhere
else for liquor it's it says or
independently so again you would have an
inconsistency there and I don't know if
we want to I'm not I'm not saying I'm
against what changing that in future
point in time but if we change it here
we have to change it alcohol too yeah Mr
chairman the chief is here could we ask
him to just come forward and I'm sure we
can straighten straighten this out for
well I I I already know it's what it
says in the other section because okay
so I'm just saying like know and you
know no no offense
Chief I'm just saying you know
we we got to use the same language Y
which direction do we want to go so Mr
chair again the interesting part is we
have that one line it actually says his
primary function so it just means that
liquor is going to take a liquor
investigator and say hey your primary
function is cannabis but that doesn't
mean it's your only function right you
may also be enforcing liquor laws as
well and and any of the other laws
allowed for by the commission so I don't
know that we need to change the section
at all I think it allows the flexibility
necessary it says that they will have
somebody who at least will have the
primary responsibility of enforcement
but it's not going to be their sole
enforcement so I I think the section is
fine just the way it is and those
positions are defined in statute as well
so I don't I I it'd be a little remiss
to to adjust or mess with the names of
investigators any other issues on
anything on on page eight and again as
as in law enforcement me just because
you have a primary job function as means
your only job function I'm sure I
officers in State Police Who weigh
trucks also pull over Speeders right
that are going down the highway as well
so there's an additional function that's
allowed so that's all this is allowing
for is that we'll have cannabis
investigators any other issues on this
page are we are you including um room
numeral three on this page
Senator where it says the inter the
authority to interpret statutes are you
including that as part of the page
if you are uh the uh the recommendation
here would be and this perhaps is the
appropriate time is to bring up whether
or not uh in the recommendation that we
have is to establish a New Hampshire
cannabis Control Commission much uh in
line with the testimony you heard from
ly silver uh at last meeting where the
Cannabis Control Commission would uh sit
as an authority in have the authority to
interpret the statutes and the rules and
administrative Rules promulgated by The
Liquor
Commission so there'll be a commission
within the commission no there would be
a a commission that uh that is
established consistent with many of the
other states that have legalized that is
a Control Commission that uh sits and
reviews and uh approves doesn't has
doesn't make the rules but approves the
rule the regulatory authority of the
Liquor Commission that makes the rules
so that there is a separate layer of
review by this independent
commission so Mr two things 541a is big
issue
so well I I just I think I think that's
an extra layer layer of government that
we we want to be cautious about I think
the Liquor Commission does it already I
I I just don't know if we need that
extra layer of government here when
that's what they're sort of set up to do
I don't know if people thought about
that
agreed it is an extra layer government
and certainly we're not in favor of an
extra layer of government when there
when there isn't a necessity but in this
case we argue that there is a necessity
in that Li commission not compris the
public health authorities um and other
uh folks that are independently minded
to look at and review and to keep the
state's best interests in mind from an
independent perspective of course the
governor and the executive Council would
establish who would sit on that
commission uh but that commission would
simply be in review of the rules and
regulations promulgated uh by that
commission maybe maybe a compromise just
not I agree with this but maybe a study
commission or legislative one just to
have something in the early stages of
that uh Mr chairman we we don't feel
that that would be a necessary U
bureaucratic step in this uh The Liquor
Commission is has run for 95 years as of
this year and we we're apprised of any
laws and statutes and and rules that we
have to run under and uh to run a
business uh by committee is not a way to
run a
business
thank take over so so the other thing I
just C Chief is we have an entire set of
administrative rule law 541a in our in
our state that requires public hearings
and requires notice and requires input
um and then on top of that it's the next
step is it serves it has to go to a
state legislative board which I serve on
J car The Joint legislative committee on
administrative rules which would then
have to also approve those rules as well
so I think there's a wellestablished
process for allowing public input
whether it's public health or anything
else and then still a legislative
oversight that make sure the rules being
implemented are consistent with the law
that's been passed well in the other
states um and I I respectfully disagree
with both the commission and and that
the other States including Massachusetts
and others that have uh promulgated
rules and regulations saw fit to
establish an independent Authority that
is not producing the rules but approves
those rules and makes and has the
authority to be able to say to the
legislation that we've looked and
reviewed these from an independent
Public Health Public Safety and other
perspective so uh those other states
have saw a fit and again you heard from
um Miss silver last week uh that
recommended that a commission uh be
established uh I think that that's a
recommendation that we make and of
course the commission decides not to go
forward with it that's fine but I think
governor and executive Council would
benefit from having an
independent-minded review commission
thank you represent H yeah I just want
to comment is that um I
know I read Boston newspapers and
evidently the Massachusetts one is
actually a problem so if nothing else
we've learned our lesson is not to
create one of these another levels of
government because uh it becomes
political and it becomes uh they they
start fighting infighting over their
Authority and we do not need it at the
end of the day if there's a public
health or is any issue that's a problem
with way our statute is written then you
bring it to the legislature and we'll
fix
it right any further comment so I I
think as we stand now again remember
that we're presenting a bill that'll be
open the public hearing um I think we'll
leave language now everyone's okay as it
is and then if we want to have a
commission that could be brought forward
as an amendment in the Bill hearing
process that consistent with everybody's
thinking great so number so number two
is okay as is number three is okay as is
number four anybody have comments on
number
four
text seeing none moving on to number
five anybody have comments on number
five All
good actually hold on I had a comment on
my
page
number
seven anybody
eight you done good all right moving on
to the regulation of cannabis uh section
318 F colon 7 um number one
Frank uh just a question this might be
actually more appropriate for liquor um
because I know in Vermont the the
timeline the 24 months was maybe a
little bit too short and so I'm
wondering if it'd be worth just asking
liquor whether like what that number
should be because that's like beyond my
comprehension but I assume that that we
want to get that number
right I think in our original uh
discussion and legislation we had
originally put 36
months so was houseal comp Commerce had
moved it to
24 was there a
reason
um we don't want them to dilly
dally I I think Mr M knows what he's
doing right so I'm sorry so Chief what
was your recommend recommended length of
time originally uh Senator we had
discussed the 36 months and and and the
the main reason behind that is because
of the investment of the people who are
going going to grow the product and
manufacture and how long it would take
them to get their facilities in place
and prepare that first grow uh it's it's
quite you it's an it's a six to eight
million doll Endeavor so uh we we want
to make sure that they have enough time
and obviously that they have that we
have enough product to sell so and we do
it in 24 months we may be able to but
we're we're really concerned if we get
to the the 24 months and we don't have
enough product to sell we don't want to
make the mistake of of opening a
business or licensing retail when we
don't have enough product to
sell so that was our that was our
discussion behind it right our
discussions around 36 months versus 24
months cut the baby in
half make it 30 is that good for your
Chief chairman he's a chairman he's
chairman sorry Chief's back he's gone
too and I'm assuming we'll move section
months any further discuss on uh Roman
numeral one and Roman numeral 2 and
Roman numeral two goes to the other page
and I actually do have a comment but
let's just look at uh Ro Roman numeral
one's okay Roman numeral two A and B
those none moving on to the next page
page 10 um Roman numerals or subro
numerals 1 through
12 any comment about and that's relative
to um operation of franchise Senator
just some cleanup language in uh Roman
well in number two I think it's at least
on my page five where it starts with the
handling um perhaps uh to make it more
precise It should read the handling
regulation manufacturer cultivation
Packaging Transportation documentation
and sale of cannabis that brings all
those functions within the
regulatory
sale and then in three the only other
recommendation would be storage and
security for facility facilities for
cannabis cannabis product again bringing
that within the regulatory Authority so
Chief can I get you to submit the that
in writings I not writing fast enough
but doesn't that some of that go beyond
what a a franchisee this is this is
specific not to the whole commission
this is about what a franchise can
do
so this this if you goes back to the the
38- F 7 regulation says not later than x
number of months 24 months I'm looking
down at B at the bottom of that page but
this is the governing statute part that
provides for the regulation does it not
I'm just looking at the bottom of that
page B I think the chief's right it is
the governing statute the B then goes
to the be is I thought was about about
the franchisees so it is so if you read
roman number two so there a CO in there
the rules shall include the following
and if you do the B procedures for the
selection and operation of a franchise
cannabis retail outlet included but not
limited to so understand it's not an
exhaustive list U it's not an absolute
list it's a list that it's some
recommendations that you at minimum have
to cover these things and you may find
other things you want to cover as well
um and then the one through 12 1 through
17 are all the minimum things that they
need to include but not again not an
exhaustive list so jeeve are you looking
to add something else on this minimum
list um relative to franchise operations
yeah the procedures regarding the
handling and then I would add regulation
manufacture cultivation packaging
transportation and documentation
yeah but they're not
manufacturers right this this is about
the franchise this is just the
franchisee this is just the the retail
location well it's the procedures but I
perhaps I'm reading it differently but
it's the procedures that they're going
to have to be held responsible
for so again this this talks about ran
numeral 2 talks about their their um Ru
making process and in subsection B we're
talking specifically the rule um rate
making process relev the franchise
Cannabis stores outlets and again A 1
through 17 is a non-exhaustive list of
minimums basically we have to at least
do these things and if the commission
finds other things it wants to do it can
add it because we we leave them that
catchall of uh including but not limited
to so I guess the question is what is
there anything other than 1 through 17
we want to add to this inclusive list or
non-inclusive list at at least as a
requirements
Chief if you want to submit that um
language we can take a look at it and
see if there's a way of incorporating it
but otherwise we're going to assume
number 1 through 17 on page 10 is okay
does testing need to be
added again this is the operation of a
franchise store testing happens at the
manufacturing and uh cultivation l i I
missed the beginning okay so number c
before before we get to see just one
mind if you go to page eight you go to
um
11 I think we need to add just to
that add State
police police officials towns Sheriff's
the deputies I think just adding state
would
that I'm not sure I heard what your
suggestion was so on on page eight lines
2 through 11 just at the end of that so
line 11 which says
towns we just want to add or or the New
Hampshire state or
state I think they just there was an
Omission in the
draft with that none I didn't think
there would
be all
right uh going on to section c training
and continuing education requirements
any questions about
that d uh procedures for selection of
cultivation facilities and Manufacturing
facilities again so D has a not limited
two language which includes Roman
numeral one and two on the second
side any questions about one and two
again these are minimums not not
uh exhaustiveness
e um procedures to hear complaints and
imposed penalties of alternative
treatment centers licensed as a cannabis
retail store to provide an adequate
Supply and variety of therapeutic um I
here oh this is I had a note just
um that the language of cannabis retail
stores we CH we were changing that
definition somewhere in the back so I
want to make sure it's that language is
consistent with whatever it is but there
should be a procedure basically that for
any retail store there's a if there's a
um violation um there's a process for
adjudication yeah and I think this the
direction we made the
Leaning
just language may be up somewhere off
sleeve
right so I'm going to leave e to come
back because we want to talk about atc's
versus retail stores and cleaning that
language up so we'll leave it as an open
item and come back to that um maybe darl
you can write up appropriate
language it will be put together and we
kind of talked about that and maybe
we'll close with that towards the end
but we'll just keep going through the
rest of the bill F uh a fee schedule for
reasonable application licens in touch
again we're all talking about the rul
making process what it needs to include
so is anybody have any questions on F I
think we got to add
transfer this what I have in my notes Fe
schedule for reasonal application licens
an annual renewal fees provided that
cultivation license fees
beered transfer from one uh entity to
another with the license say that again
to what was there suggested am I'm not
sure why transfer fit this is just them
setting PS for what a license costs what
a you know and and yeah but if you can
transfer the license it's my point right
oh you can sell your Fran as a
franchisee you can sell I can imagine it
be to approval but I'm Afra I can sell
it so have a we add that as another item
when we get to the back here all the way
at the end right under here because it's
a requirement I don't know that it falls
under a fee schedule for transfer of
license as just a general process of
what happens if the owner wants to
transfer a license right so we'll add
a We'll add a letter
in add an O at the end of of section
whatever we're at here section question
uh question are we past uh uh G as in
George the qualifications
yeah
so I think for cannabis offenses well
the problem that here is that that
language is so broad that so for example
if you had someone that was convicted
multiple times of operating illegal
grows even by State Statute right that
that would not be um something that
could be consider Ed and I think that
that's that's overly broaden language so
again this if if I could just to say
what this says that they're required to
create a rule that um talks about the
qualifications for lure and it must
include also who's disqualified
automatically from that lure as well
that's what this letter G says as I read
it so I think Canabis offense it's one
thing to have you know on your record
possession even possession with intent
but if you are I guess
cultivating on a you know 100 yard field
here you're basically in in the
trafficking business at that point and
that would be construed as a cannabis
offense technically so I guess the we
want to there should be more specific
language as to what uh you want to
exclude here for disqualification and I
think the intent here is folks that may
have violations for personal possessory
amounts and things of that nature but uh
what this does is effective
um allow someone who operates a 500 acre
illegal grow under New Hampshire law so
I think to accomplish that we after
which
says line 19 says operation of a canis
establishment you put a period that then
which say and to strike the rest of
it would that work we we definitely want
to take that disqualifying stuff out I
mean you know if you if you've had an
established illegal grow you're saying
hey I'm not going to follow the rules
and we we want above board citizens with
rules I think I think from our
perspective I I I I'm okay with what the
chief is talking about in terms of like
people who are engaged in grows I but I
do think it would be important to have
language in there to clarify that people
who have passed marijuana possession
offense records particularly with the
disparity and arrests we have in New
Hampshire that we're not you know
automatically cutting those folks off um
from the opportunity to engage in this
so I think you know figuring out that
middle ground there so maybe at the next
have a middle ground because I I agree
possession is totally different than
trafficking right so the traffic are
much I I'm with you on that so what
maybe come with some proposed language
we'll revisit so actually was I think Mr
chair we can simply on G saying that the
qualifications and disqualifications for
lenser that are directly and
demonstrably related to the operation of
a Canabis establishment period done and
that requires them now to say what if
you have these things on your record
you're automatically disqualified
otherwise you're you you're that's good
answer right so I think we just add
qualifications and disqualifications for
lure that are directly and demonstrably
related to the operation of cannabis
establishment period
and that works all
anybody
I
okay okay um is J has to do with the
transportation did we is that where we
want to
implement some of the warehouse
distribution rules or is
that well I think we need to add the
language from the op from the
distribution language that they'll
establish the same qualifications right
for requirements for transportation
warehousing and distribution is that
what you want to add yes
like the put all right so in J inj
Transportation warehousing
transportation and
distribution and
distribution and then at the end
transported or
distributed well transported warehoused
and distributed transported warehoused
yeah everybody okay with that change to
Jay
okay reasonable security requirements
reach type of Canabis establishments
establishment um
I L um restrictions on where cannabis
may be located consistent with
Provisions in this
chapter again this is about them
developing
regulations standards for the operation
of Testing Laboratories including
personnel
and again this we get we get into that
conversation we had with the lab company
that came in last week Chief sorry to
break you slow there but for the
requirements of uh restrictions of where
they may be
located is should it be something should
we put something in this bill I
understand that uh a lot of come to
rules about so many feet from a school
or an area that's very important should
we put that that's in here somewhere it
is yeah somewhere else in that's that's
in here in a separate section I think
it's
um I think what's there now I'm sure
we're going to have a healthy debate on
that
one um so back to n requirements for the
testing cannabis Canabis products
limited but not included so again this
is all the conversation around um
testing for all the different um
carcinogens and and contaminants and
that kind of stuff again it's not an
exhaustive list um and I think we
have again including but not limited to
language so it allows them to expand
based on the input of that Lab company
we had before that talks about what
should be tested for and what not and
creating that
list so Roman numeral the sub Roman
numeral one 2 3 four five six seven
eight n any comments on any of those
that we think we need to add into that
lab as a again this is a minimum list
list any any comment seeing none right
uh I just want you to know at Amsterdam
which is covered with canals covered
with it was rained every day we were
there and there is no regulation of mold
stores what else happened
[Music]
so number Roman numeral number
three
um so I think Mr chair this might go
along with that other one we left open
for you on uh e relative to the um
alternative treatment centers
and Mr frair I think that we should
probably change that to 30 months to be
consistent with yep
30 thank you catch that this section
needs to
incorporate I get I what I saying so the
direction we were kind of going in was
perhaps if if an ATC were to apply to be
a franchisee and if they were granted
that they were you know selected and
assuming they they met the
criteria uh rather than have a dual
store they would basically become a
retail store but the therapeutic
products would be its own separate
industry they kind of would be grandf
followed in for manufacturing purposes
and leave it to them to and how they
they want to distribute that to other
franchises again it's we're not going to
force them to sell that but that means
any franchisee would be able to sell
therapeutic products if they wish they
still would need the card but I and the
I know some representatives from the
atcs are here I think for the most part
we're they're on on board with that you
know obviously there's
some more detailed concerns but I think
that would get rid of the Dual store the
dual lights the having the two signs up
and all that confusion it kind of sets
it one One Direction I'm wondering that
I mean that's an issue that I think we
need to hash out um and I don't know if
uh Mike H wants to weigh in on that
issue I think the collocation issue is
one that we really do need to hash out
well yes well but I think what what
we're saying is it's if an ATC wants to
remain an ATC that is within their
that's their discre they can do that
they're already there if they want to
have become a retail St right rather
than have all this dual license all this
in you know their sign and the state
whatever they're be they're coming to
the state wanting to be a franchise at
that point the the long term of this the
brand is not the the sign at your store
the brand is the product is they give
Like Liquor Jack Daniels Jim Beam Johnny
whatever it is that that's the brand
right so they're gonna have that but I
think I think I would like to hear from
Mike hle and maybe some of the atcs
about about this issue and how it would
affect our existing businesses in New
Hampshire I would like to hear some
additional Mr chairman and yeah we'll
keep moving through the bill maybe when
we get towards the end today what's our
time hour I think this is a larger issue
that we and and and I cannot
underestimate that the the issue is that
um the
tax that the atcs don't pay any tax and
a and b is there's no cap on how much
THC is in the product
I think all those those those are still
subject to the whole process but I think
this the basis that what I'm talking
about the ATC product could be subject
to the franchise fee still uh but that
also gives us an opportunity to perhaps
lower that franchise fee there is a
public interest in lowering that amount
to keep the retail price lower but um
let's keep going through this but I
think before we close up maybe in about
15 minutes we'll let the atcs
and take we go take the station and my P
too I really I think this is a critical
issue for exempting businesses so I do
before we I don't think we reach consent
hold on Mr Holt is not an owner of an
ATC well that's like a therapeutic let
me let me keep talking don't interrup me
what I'm saying is that this is a
critical policy issue my col runs the
program atcs are existing businesses
before I'm comfortable making any
decision I don't think there's consensus
on the committee I would like to hear
how that would impact the existing
program the patients and the businesses
I think from the Department's
perspective we have the business
perspective we have the Department's
perspective which hopefully is also
thinking about the patients I think
before I can make a a decision about
where it should go I would like to hear
hear from all the parties maybe you guys
have already made your decision but I
have
not no I think that was the point I
think we it's a bigger conversation that
we need to talk about and maybe we can
skip that piece right now and move on to
something else that we can get consensus
and can you moving through the bill
let's keep moving but maybe in about 15
minutes we'll we'll switch all right so
number four um again we have the 30
month change and I would like that
online um so we're on page 13 now on
line 34 um number Roman numeral four I'd
like to change that again to 30 months
and then add online 37 that but not
limited to language to give the them
room on the rule making to deal with all
the issues that they may that may crop
that
I think most States distinguish whether
not I'm sorry so let's let's so Frank
let's go uh thank you um so I know
looking at the new futures um handout
that they gave us they had some thoughts
on this so I'm not if it'd be
appropriate if we could call Kate to
give their opinion on this or if we want
to
push thank you very much uh members of
the committee again um my name is Kate
fried VI vice president of advocacy for
new Futures I did send the committee our
side by side with the principles as well
as revised language I'm sending out a
copy again I know I brought it last time
but just in case you need a revised copy
so I speak to this on page two of the
document that has um suggested
edits um I do have to say that uh a lot
of our previous concerns in uh within
our principles around advertising
marketing labeling things like that um
have been addressed I will also bring
attention to uh what Dr Silver's
comments were in her draft she actually
um did an excellent job as well probably
better language than me so I defer to
that as well um but there were two
issues in particular on page
14 um I do think that
um we uh need to tweak that language uh
establishing potency limits for cannabis
products and the maximum amount of THC
that may be included in each cannabis
product serving so if you don't want to
put a number in there now that's fine I
will say 20 is way too high that's
dangerously High even the industry had
said that in their comments there is no
state that allows 20 in the serving size
the average is five I believe 10 is in
Maine um so I think that's very
dangerous to have that set at 20 in
statute um I would also urge the
committee to make sure there are potency
limits within the statute that is
something that we heard very clearly
from Dr Silver on evolving um uh science
uh that we've had uh with the connection
on um psychosis um and other mental
health issues um the other thing that I
have included um this is well that's
jumping ahead to page 15 too when we
start to talk about labeling I can hold
on that let's get through Page let's get
through that but page 14 one so it says
20 I think that I'm hearing that's way
too high M does 10 uh not saying we 10's
going to be the final number but we at
least agree to reduce that to 10 for the
time being Mr fine i' I'd leave it as as
their recommending and not put any limit
in there because now we're basically
going to put a limit in but then give
the commission statutory authority to
change the limit after we've we've
already set the limit as a legislature I
think that's a little confusing I think
if we just change it to to establish
again this is about rul making and what
rules they have to make and one of them
is in the rule making we're asking them
to establish a maximum amount of T that
may be included in each cannabis product
serving period and let the let it just
end right there so get ready to accept
that the commission me so strike that
language strike as 20 from as 20
milligrams all the way to the end of the
sentence and that just gives the
commission the right through public
through the rules making process to
establish a limit including Public
Health input and everything else without
setting statute so on the segue with
that exactly with what you said as far
as public health input on page three we
actually offered additional language
under number eight um this is not me
let's see if we can finish C well it
ties into C it's related to that so we
don't um I think you heard last week
there is evolving science all the time
on potency limits you know um we're not
really sure what that number is but that
doesn't mean we shouldn't be doing
anything um our partners at the at the
Liquor Commission while they we I think
they do great work and they know the
products um I think it's important to
have some kind of advisory committee to
assist with um advising on public health
issues such as potency limits um based
on the experts that are out there on the
on the science I'm not saying that it
should be um an advi a regulatory body
or take the place of the rules process
but just an advisory body that the
commission could rely on for the latest
Public Health um and most upto-date
evidence-based information on potency
limits and serving sizes so that's how
you would get to assisting that
commission find that
number have the doctor and lqu any any
comment I just wanted to clarify so if
we didn't have something here there
would be nothing in this bill that had a
product serving size limit well would
require the commission to establish one
we're not establishing as legisl
a product
service so one of the reasons why we
should probably leave that in in there
is what what if we get it wrong and our
constituents elect a new body that want
us to make a change we won't have the
ability to make a change it would only
we well through legislation we can
always we can always change a rule I'm
thinking what I'm saying is I think
having making a 10 I'm not saying future
legislation will increase that I'm sure
if if liquor finds the a good reason for
that to be increased they would come to
the legisl I think just having I think
the one thing is we don't want to do too
much too soon and then try to roll it
back I think going backwards is going to
be tough Senator Whitley yeah I I think
if we're going I understand the very I
share the same concerns about removing
all sort of limits in the statute I
think we're exceeding some of our
Authority there perhaps if we are going
to do that we also need you know this um
you know advisory this public health
advisory perspective I think it's sort
of a middle ground so this is
recommended by new Futures on on page
three of their memo at eight I think
that is a middle ground between what the
chief was proposing and what we
discussed maybe would be an extra lay
uner layer of government I think the
addition if we're going to remove those
limits if we're going to give all our
authority to Ru Mak I think having that
public health I wouldn't say back stop
but uh uh there's no partic
participation would be helpful does that
make sense I don't think there's any
harm with what um new Futures is
proposing in on number eight yeah I
think it's a a middle ground from what
the chief was proposing yeah I mean I
think when we heard I was not here last
week the week before about all the sort
of public health advocacy and how little
role they've had in other states I mean
it sort of makes me feel like if there
isn't a limit set now like are they
really going to have any real role in
the future you know even if we say they
will will they really um and so I I I
think it's always concerning when we
even I mean if most places are five
starting it's it's much easier as
everybody's mentioned to go up than to
go back five most plac are five well no
I'm saying if most I I'm just looking at
you know some of the the testimony from
from last week and I'm just saying you
know if I saw California was 10 and
Maine is 10 I see or some are five I
mean NIH recommends five I'm just asking
I don't know um what you know in other
states that are have recreational legal
cannabis what is the average limit we
certainly shouldn't be above that and
what is that what I believe it's
actually five and Vermont and
Massachusetts are five too and that's
another reason you know again we can be
fluid with what's in statute and rely on
that through Ru making because there's
some time for that but we would want
that public health expertise I would be
uncomfortable with setting it with 10 in
the statute I still feel that that's too
high I'm not sure I'm at 10 either I
just 20 is too high so she's correct it
is five so now we're down to 10 so who
wants it to say who wants it to be five
please raise your hand yeah right well
five has it so uh Mr chair I I the whole
one of our issues here is to be
competitive if Maine has all these
stores surrounding us that are selling
it at 10 I think we should do 10 but
then include the health this health
entity do they can then make a case that
the number should go down so I think
yeah with with all due respect but I
think this is no one's saying you can't
buy more than one product this each
product has a max potency right you can
have so you can buy 10K I believe me I
understand the
situation uh but I'm just saying this
what consumers are are aware of what
they're thinking about uh you and if the
fact that um I I would say our number
one competitor is going to be main uh
then why why would we handicap our
stores right out of the box why not just
stick with the take the 10 because
that's what the that was the president
and then let the health health this
health if this health people are going
to be able to start doing some research
and doing some know you knowledge
gaining then they can make a case going
forward to lower before I get to the the
hands we do have a person from Maine or
I think he actually lives in the state
but
he's if you want come up to the mic
perhaps try to persuade this this
Commission of why 10 is the PR but come
microphone I just want you to know the
the different one thing that you don't
consider right we're competing with
other states when I make a job of gummy
say right in Maine we make 10 pieces for
100 milligrams because that's the
maximum dose so we have jars of a 100 if
we want to make a jar of fives just
understand what happens is your cost
goes way up your packaging doubles
because you you need twice as much
volume to put 20 pieces in instead of 10
and the ingredients go up so it's a cost
issue thing I think five or 10 works
either way but I'm just wanted to bring
up to you guys to explain the uh the
other consideration that happens when we
put this stuff on the Shelf
so
Whitley yeah I think um five makes sense
to me I think I I understand the
competitive uh advantage that we are
looking for but I don't think that this
is the place where we want to seek that
competitive Advantage I think this is a
critical Public Health we talked a lot
about um public health and child
protection and I think this is a piece
where um it's consistent with most
surrounding states I think this is a
piece that we can really weigh in
on do I I agree I think that it's hard
to put uh public or profitability over
Public Health like I understand this
needs to be profitable but like when you
think about like increasing ER visits
for kids when they get a handle on these
things like it's it's you know it can
always go up I I I I think the the key
is if we go to five
it can be changed to 10 20 if you're at
20 going down to 10 going down to five
is Not Practical so I rather start slow
move up than go too high and move back
down I think that's where where I'm at
so so Mr CH there a recommendation just
changing striking the accept language so
the commission can't change the law and
just set the instead of 20 milligrams
change it to five and yes correct and
then paragraph eight in what new Futures
provide us
basically I'm not sure that would go
under section c but we want to put that
in into this working model somewhere
does anyone have any problem with
that no I think that I think that's a
great a great addition to keep that I
mean I think we're going to be the
leader hopefully we're going to be do in
New Hampshire for the leader on this
public health perspective and having
this advisory body I think would be
really helpful Chief I I'd like to hear
what the chief says because that's kind
of a compromise on what um Lynn silver
had testified I mean she she was asking
for something
nature can I ask on
yeah so the way this is written
including a Prohibition on vaporizing
devices that include toxic or addictive
additives I I
understand this is written is that
intended to maybe not mix THD with like
nicotine but I don't think we want to
ban vaping of nicotine products does
this do that but
inadvertently
anyone I'm on page 14 lines 15 to
20 yeah it seems like it does because we
all know that nicotine's toxic right I
mean and it's addictive so yeah I and I
think that there are other I mean I
think that the the language is still
important but maybe taking nicotine out
of that because there are other things
that you can vaporize that could be
mixed with cannabis like katom or some
other you know things that are currently
legal but bad I don't think we want to
we could prohibit like THC being mixed
with
nicotine I don't think that's a bad bad
policy but I think number D has
to make it clear that we're not Banning
vaping products that involve nicotine
back I mean we definitely want to
prohibit some of these chemical
compounds that are not approved or
tested or
yeah yeah I I see what you were saying
because it's not it's saying that on the
Cannabis accessories specifically so it
really doesn't have anything to do with
what you're putting in the vapor the
vaporizer the accessory it's just the
accessory itself is that is that right
that
he's right okay just double checking
wouldn't be the first time the
legislator made that mistake that
consequences they didn't intend so all
right so otherwise are we good with the
written good move on to
E
this is a big one with the signs I
personally any billboard signage you
know I don't support any of that I think
driving through
Massachusetts
it's it's over the top what what they're
doing there with the advertisements
every billboard these neon Billboards
it's I mean it's just what it
is used go back from maned him what did
they do over there there's no
signs but does anyone have any issue
with the with uh PL 22 to 45 it goes on
add one one thing you want to consider
we advertise on billboards in New
Hampshire from Maine so if you're going
to stop billboard advertising just don't
stop it for New Hampshire because
because we could still
advertise you on your Billboards unless
there's some restriction on that I would
have to ban all advertising not just
instate correct
just that make sense I I appreciate that
especially that seems to be against your
own
interest so I really I really do
appreciate that thank you you just saved
him
money I think um we were going to stop
around 12 that's I think what we were
trying to get at
um but there was a citizen that wanted
to testify yes
um you you're recognized that some
riddle
yeah and after after witness is done the
represents from the atcs if you don't
mind kind of
discussing the idea I had of kind of
putting everything together maybe just
for the rest of the commission again I
would like to hear from Michael H at the
same time if Michael H wants to join the
atcs even though he's a they have
different interests like the atcs have
business interests and the the
department has public health and patient
if Mr hle wants to join the atcs he's
welcome to join
me thank you uh Mr chair members of the
commission uh my name is Jim Riddle uh
Lambs breath seeds Hillsboro New
Hampshire and I've attended every one of
your meetings and uh thank you for the
opportunity to speak and thank you for
the hard work you're doing too um and uh
I spoke about a month ago or so and and
summarized a grower survey that I worked
with the Farm Bureau and the Northeast
organic Farmers Association and I'm not
going to repeat that but I did uh uh
send around a handout which has the
those results in more detail and I guess
um one of my main concerns as a lifelong
farmer is maximizing opportunities for
granted State farmers we've got the land
we got buildings we got equipment we
have knowledge growing crops and let's I
don't hear that being discussed so I
just want to make sure that
opportunities uh are given to Farmers in
this state and just also want to point
out the uh recent vote in Ohio uh
57% of the public uh voted to uh support
uh adult use marijuana or cannabis as
and that includes hom growing up to 12
plants per household uh so overwhelming
there but uh one of my concerns I'm a
licensed hemp grower I grow seed and uh
the whole issue of cannabis seed is not
being addressed in your legislation yet
uh but Minnesota was just before Ohio
was the 23rd state to legalize and they
did establish some very uh I think
reasonable realistic uh regulations for
cannabis seed production requiring that
seed producers have a state permit and
that they properly label their seeds if
the seed makes a
THC claim I mean seed contains no THC so
but the parent coming or the plant
coming from it they would need to have
certificate of analysis of the mother
plant uh to to have it actually be
verified they also have to do uh germ
tests uh weed seeds all the things it
takes to put a good quality seed on the
market so I think that is something that
you need to think about or the
Commission in rule writing needs to take
into consideration and I don't have
copies for everybody but I will leave a
copy for the record of the Minnesota
Department of agricultures uh
regulations for cannabis seed production
I think it's a good model and encourage
you to take a look at
um I think one of your goals that I've
gotten from attending the meeting is to
try and treat cannabis a lot like
alcohol it's going to be legal and you
know if it's legal to have uh um you
know so the things about public
consumption should mirror uh the uh uh
alcohol but also what are The Possession
limits for
alcohol there aren't any I can buy as
much beer beer Wine Liquor as I want
what are the potency limits for alcohol
there aren't any I can buy 151 rum I can
buy Ever CLE 190 proof 95% essentially
pure grain alcohol um you know some
things can be left to the public to
individuals to make judgments like they
are with alcohol right now so you know
just also in alcohol home brewing is
allowed wine Mak is allowed hom growing
should be allowed on those same lines
and just finally I will tell you though
yeah I understand people keep bringing
up hom grow I will tell you that is an
absolute deal breaker with this bill if
it's in here we might as well just
adjourn for the day and call it a day
it's not it will never make it off the
Finish Line yeah well it's a critical
part of cutting the illicit market and
it's also just a personal Liberty and we
do already have HP 411 that passed the
house overwhelmingly tabled in the
Senate allowing medical hom grow maybe
they go separately but I think it could
be merged uh into this bill so just I I
think it's a critical component other
states everyone around us allows hom
grow um it doesn't undercut the market
um and then I just uh finally um getting
back to the point about conflicts of
interest that the chief raise that was
raised by uh your speaker from
California last week um you know not
letting the Cannabis industry
essentially set the regulations but the
way
this franchise bill is being
constructed the commission is both the
marketer and the regulator there's
there's no separation of interests so
they have an interest in maximizing
sales as well as limiting public you
know entrance limiting competition um
and uh I do think there is a role for a
cannabis Control Commission that can
include Public Health that really is
independent takes a big picture and has
some Powers because the commission does
have a vested interest um and you you
can't really separate that with this
model so uh those are just things I
wanted to share with you oh on one thing
you were talking about today in the bill
language about uh the cultivation
tiers based just it just says size it's
really should be focused on the square
footage of flowering space because
there's so many different types of
production models indoor hydroponic
indoor in living soil outdoor uh all all
different ways just the word size is not
sufficient it's really how many square
foot of flowering plants or the annual
gross sales of the operation but
something that's more Equitable than
just that word size so I just wanted to
point that out and maybe that could be
addressed in Ru making but you you've
got to be um you know
specific thank
questions good all right
are so I for the rest of purposes today
are there any representatives from the
atcs
here
in you can you can hand that up thank
you and Michael Holtz here from DHHS do
up so I ju I just want to be clear again
you know atc's have their own interest
which is very valuable the state running
the program has their own input which is
valuable I I often I don't want to
conate those interests and so I
understand that they are separate and I
think that's important so I think we
should give them each due due course for
input okay and the topic that I'm I'm I
think I'm hoping that is addressed by
three Witnesses is this idea of having
two signs for one store I can't wrap my
head around
that no one's making any ATC join the
retail Market if they choose to join the
retail Market the certain conditions
that it's going to entail all right it's
done on a voluntary basis what I was
kind of getting at
is if they're going to do that they they
are giving up essentially their
storefront that they have
now they still have their product brand
but rather than limit those seven atcs
to selling just the therapeutic products
there's no reason why they can't
distribute those to any franchisee you
know it would still be the same you
still need a therapeutic card but
there's no reason why their branded
product wouldn't be sold in other
franchisees however I think we would
limit going forward we're not going to
allow more manufacturers of ATC great
products that's kind of where I was
going with this and I thought that kind
of gives it increases their distribution
potential but at the same time if they
don't want to give up their store from
they don't have to to join the retail
Market I think is going to be difficult
having both of those and I also thought
some of the rules and how that's going
to be implemented it's difficult to have
rules made by one body expecting liquor
to enforce it it's going to be kind of a
fine line so I
thought some of the ATC program would be
re not eliminate but reassign under
liquor that's a much more confusing
process than I just and sound that's
kind of where I was at um any comment on
that any anything you want yeah and I
and I would from my perspective um you
know I that's one perspective um I also
think it's important to think through
this issue broader without having
without sort of deciding the issue
before we've really heard all the
perspective about it about collocation
about the future of the program so I
would like to hear sort of a broader
perspective about that about what this
forward thank you for the record my name
is Michael Holt I'm the administrator of
the therapeutic cannabis program within
the Department of Health and Human
Services thanks for the opportunity to
readdress this question um from our
perspective this is an important issue
that will take more than five minutes to
fully explore and um and and digest um
I'd like to start by saying the draft
that has been
circulated um is a workable model where
the
atc's um have a separate uh license type
that is not the franchise type uh where
there is essentially dual licensure um
essentially requires uh cooperation and
collaboration between the Department of
Health and Human Services and the Liquor
Commission um that allows a separation
of of
allows a dual regulatory structure this
is a model that works in other states it
is workable it is it may be a bit more
complex and complicated than doing away
with the therapeutic cannabis program in
its entirety um so the draft so to
conclude the that introduction the draft
as proposed is a workable model for
both the department the program the
patients in the program and I believe
the
atc's now we are at the mercy of the
legislature and if the legislature
chooses to make decisions that undercut
the
program we we will have to live with
those legislative decisions
however without seeing in front of me
language that you're proposing Senator
abbis which is which is something
different which is not exactly clear to
me on a on the page it's hard for me to
comment on how workable or how uh at
what risk that places the program so
when I hear that the draft in front of
us is not what you want me to comment on
I'm I'm gonna have a hard time saying
that that's a pro that's a problematic
um uh proposal
um I think I I don't remember uh I've
been here at every every session I don't
know what you have changed or have
agreed to change the definition of for
cannabis retail store um if the atcs
become
franchises that's a different model than
what's being presented on paper and so I
would like to understand the model more
so I can comment more but again the
model presented on the draft is a
workable model requires collaboration
between two agencies requires a dual
licensing structure which is entirely
workable to be worked out in rul making
and in collaboration with the liquor
department
comment um so my name is Brandon Pollock
I'm the uh chair of the board of tascal
Wellness we operate in Dober Lebanon and
Keen I also have experience operating in
several other canis
markets and my name is Keenan Blum I'm
the CEO of Grant Leaf cannabis and thank
you for all of your time here working on
this and making good policy yep yeah we
appreciate it so couple things just
generally from our perspective first it
is essential as drafted to remove the uh
nonprofit requirement if we're going to
be able to participate in the new
program that would be a a really
competitive diff disadvantage and no
real logic to maintain that um from our
view serving both uh therapeutic
patients and recreational customers in
the same building is the simplest and
best approach uh I operate stores in
Massachusetts that have that model we've
served literally millions of
recreational customers hundreds of
thousands of patients there's no issues
you have a separate counter or the
technology today allows us to simply
just press a button on a computer and it
can serve a patient versus a customer so
that's really
not not operationally challenging at all
uh of course we'd like to keep our brand
but we understand that could um POS some
challenges for a franchisee so um I
that um you know we we do recommend for
an ATC a licensing Model A license model
some sort of expanded ATC license that
allows some certainty of Licensing
moving forward uh on the manufacturing
cultivation and Retail
side from a practical perspective the
quicker that you can have some
infrastructure become licensed
uh the faster this program can launch
and the faster customers can go away
from Massachusetts and shop within their
own
state so I think that's you know from
our view I think what we've heard here
is all is all
workable um I think the the key though
is not having to have two separate
physical locations I think that would
really jeopardize serving patients
because it would be very hard as that
business declines in the future to to
keep the purely therapeutic store going
do you think it's beneficial that if any
franchise retail operation had the
opportunity or at least option to uh
also sell you know therapeutic grade
products to patients yeah I I think for
patients it would be with the caveat
there has to be some extra educational
materials and training provided to staff
and um you know from the manufacturers
to the stores some support so that you
know there's a lot of discussion about 5
milligrams you know as a dose if that is
indeed a public self safety issue then
we want to make sure that therapeutic
patients are being educated correct me
if I'm wrong though I don't believe
there's any requirement on training
today am I correct right now to if
you're going to work in a therapeutic
store one of your there's no work you
may have internal policies but there's
no rule or law that has any training
required I I would I would hope that any
product you sell you make sure the trans
yeah there there's a variety of
Education that we have to provide uh for
example even physically we have to have
a room in each store just for con
patients okay so what about the the
employees in inside the facility are
they required any type of
training right now under present Ru
making yeah I can let Mike I guess
answer the rules I know we have policies
question the department requires the
atcs to provide initial and annual
training to their
employees we do not prescribe the type
of training or the courses that must be
taken but we require ongoing annual
training that is related to their job it
is up to the ATC to choose what is
appropriate for their employees to be
trained on how do you know an at how
would you know that an ATC is complying
with that we inspect the atcs for all of
our administrative rules our
administrative rules require training so
during our inspections we go in and look
at Personnel files uh we require
documentation of training to be in uh in
those Personnel files but is there
anything specific to what that training
has to be it needs to be job appropriate
we're not we we trying to not to not to
over regulate the atc's the atcs know
best what they need to be trained on in
terms of cannaboid profile talking with
patients uh we give them topics uh
confidentiality uh product safety
referral to substance use treatment um
uh adverse side effects we give them
topics that they have to they have to be
trained on
um and that training needs to be job
overregulation cultivating cannabis they
know what their their uh their employees
need well I understand they have an
interest from just a pure liability
perspective to train their employees
without any rule or law necessary I get
that I'm just saying right now if we
were to right now what is the way you're
going to enforce that rule saying that
they have to be trained you're saying
you look at the Personnel files but I'm
just asking what is that it says oh this
person did training does it even say
specifically what they were trained on
did they were they even paying attention
during the video that was play I mean we
do not we're not part of the training so
I can't tell you if people are falling
asleep during the training or not um
that's not part of the documentation the
documentation includes the name of the
person being trained the name of the
trainer the topic of the training the
date of the training and that
documentation is in the personnel file I
mean what I'm saying is that we don't
prescribe the topics we don't prescribe
the the the the format of the training
uh we require the atcs to train all of
their employees initially and ongoing in
job appropriate topics
I I I think we're I think the issues
that we're talking about here are the I
think we're mixing two issues about the
education that ATC technicians Patient
Service Associates provide to the
patients versus the training that the
atcs provide I think there's a little
mingling of of these two topics and I'm
I'm trying to tease them out by
answering your very specific
questions and I apologize if I'm not
giving you the answer that you're
looking for I'm just trying to inquire
about how that's would ever be enforced
because my biggest concern is is having
the Liquor Commission take over the
enforcement side of this where there's I
come across several rules that I feel
are very difficult to ever enforce on
any on any level so I try to get to the
bottom of whether they can even be
enforced they sound good on paper but
then when it comes to the reality of
that and then my my bigger concern is if
you have an ATC rules and laws you know
that are I would say virtually
impossible to enforce mixing that with
the New Hampshire franchise brand could
be problematic because that would then
be a negative on all I'm just explaining
the concept the problem is that's why
I'm asking how these would be enforced
we might disagree on the ability to
enforce that I mean we we do enforce it
in the way we enforce it and that is
they're required to have X hours of
annual training and initial training the
atcs need to document that training we
go in and make sure that every single
employee in the ATC has a doc has
documented training it's it's not hard
to enforce it's it's rather it's rather
straightforward so I guess my question
now for the atcs is if we were not have
the the Dual license anymore in this one
every franchise you essentially could
sell
both a working model or business model
how how would that
work I think um you'd want to require
first of all uh educational materials at
all the franchise stores that's easy to
verify that's very common in other
markets um we provide that in New
Hampshire as well so there's pamphlets
that therapeutic patients get they it
includes uh a little log that they can
track their use and how it may affect
them it includes information on misuse
of cannabis safe use different dosing
strategies um so requiring educational
materials
and you know I think that it's good to
train certain staff on therapeutic
cannabis that's up to the you know
committee here to decide whether that's
mandated or not but I think some sort of
discussion about
having staff that interact with patients
have a higher level of training is not a
bad idea and last question is there any
other thought on having this guess the
regulatory side and the W making side
not be eliminated for therapeutic
purposes I'm just talking you take it
from DHHS and it kind of falls under the
liquor side kind of having
one I feel like the they're going to be
pass with enforcing some of these
Provisions maybe they should be involved
more in the ru making
process is there any comment on that
yeah I mean our our comment is we can
work through any um regulatory Authority
we're not we don't have an opinion of
who it should be or whether it's one or
two it's uh as long as the rules do not
contradict each other that's the key and
one of the rationals is to avoid
contradicting rules is having if
Liquor's going to be liquor commissions
being involved in the make rule making
for recreation perhaps going forward
some of the therapeutic rules would be
helpful if they were involved in that
process that's just where I'm going with
Senator Whitley yeah on that issue I I
think that DHHS has a because the goals
of the program are different right this
is a therapeutic canesas program we have
patients to keep in mind and the
regulation is important from that
perspective from DHHS because that's
their mission right is the health and
wellness of our citizens so I think it's
very possible to have this co- uh
regulation I I do think if we're looking
at advertising la
packaging you know those kind of things
I agree we need consistency but I very
much think that DHHS and Liquor
Commission are very much able to to work
together um because there are just we
have to think about the purposes of the
program and they are different and they
have their own value and so we don't
want to say to our patients that you
know their involvement in that program
is not valuable uh and because they need
it for health reasons so I think
co-regulation is very possible but I do
think that we need some continuity for
advertising and packaging and labeling
requirements but I think that is very
doable so let's say there is a
inconsistency who who own who owns the
day the DHHS rule or the r b recogition
it depends on the on the program right
if it's a franchise e violation it would
be with a Liquor Commission if it's an
ATC violation it would be with DHHS
commission is the one I I I have a a
very specific question on this issue but
it's important and this is the the the
discussion of five milligram versus
unlimited and that the question is set
that because of the medical because of
the atc's what it
does we don't have the
limits but you can't have in the same
location this other requirement that
does have a limit but they're saying
that they do do have that in other
states I understand that but those other
states don't have the franchise model
those other states are they're
independent they're they're that's
that's the model that you the Senate
killed okay and it's unfair Market
advantage to allow some of these retail
stores exactly franchisees to have that
not right some not so what I'm hearing
is from from Mike that if we allow the
atcs to stand alone have their thing all
they're asking for is to remove the
nonprofit status they want to be
for-profit but they continue to not want
to have to pay a tax and they want to be
able to go beyond the five
milligrams so obviously that's a totally
different model than if they want to be
retail the retail you have just
determined this five okay youve said
this five is Magic is an important
number to you the whole point is you
can't have anything more than five in
that location that's why the two cannot
mix the that if they want to have they
want to sell recreational they need to
open up a they apply for a franchisees
get their agreement get their you know
the get the r and then they they can pay
the 15% and be limited to the 5
milligrams can I just say Mr chair that
we need to regain some control about how
this commission is interacting with each
other I think the doctor has had her
hand up other had I think are you
raising a point of order yes a point of
order we need to be more respectful of
our process here and our other
commission members and you know
interrupting each other and letting each
other finish and people that are raising
their hands you stated your point of
order I will call much tighter again
like I I I and I apologize to the doctor
if the do Dr Young Senator again like we
need to be more respectful of letting
people finish their point and having
people respond to that and and not
interrupting each other so I would ask
that the chair takes I apologize for
that again please
I I will remind the the representative
who just got back to maner vam to not
interrupt other
members I know he didn't mean it mean it
that way but I think it does it doesn't
just apply to you representative just
interrupted move it applies all
committee MERS but you just interrupted
me so if I'm G to hearing we're not
going to interrupt anyone that includes
me all right and Dr Young me as well
thank and he interrupted again I and Dr
jren
I'm I'm sure if I did offend you you
would definitely let me know but if I do
apologize um as a Collegiate rugby
player I'm confident I can take you
down kidding of course um I'm gonna
rewind a little bit because my comment
was to something was said a while ago
now but I I think as you're talking
about a model that would have like all
franchise store have medical uh
potentially have medical product
available I just think that you know if
that were the case that the education
component is really important here
especially if we have a potency limit of
5 Mig for the recreational customer and
none for the non-recreational customer
um I think it's really important that
they're educated because not all Edibles
are the same and so if you have
something that's 20 or 50 milligrams
versus five we just need to make sure
that the patients understand that that's
different um and so I just think like
making sure that that is absolutely
essential if there is medical outside of
now
thank you everyone um I do believe that
we can meet that requirement and and be
able to provide Educational Services
across the entire State I'd love to see
greater patient access to these products
on top of what we're trying to do here
to legalize it for adults I well I
personally provided over 500
consultations each on average about an
hour for the first year years in
business we have found that consumers in
general are becoming more aware of the
standards the general Community is more
aware of safety with cannabis
consumption and understanding of edible
dosage things like that we've also
dialed in our documentation and the
things we've provided through thousands
and thousands of hours of Labor in order
to make sure that they're clear concise
and able to be understood by all
individuals who are able to read at
above a third grade level was our Target
we could provide those throughout as
well as additional services that can be
reached and accessed so that any store
that was providing those products in the
state is able to direct people or
provide them directly basic services and
allow them to access greater Services as
needed to ensure safety um that's been a
priority for us and now at this point
with those with those documents with the
ability to do that we're now not doing
you know six we had we had three
full-time patient Educators we're down
to one and a half a full-timer and a
part-timer and we are no longer doing
you know 10 15 20 consults a day many of
the patients are more educated so I do
not believe quite the same level is
required that was before and that we
have much more basis to provide those
services without issue now I was under
the impression that it's been consistent
from state to state when they allow a
recreational program the number of
therapeutic patients will drop it just
we can get into the reasons why but it
just will drop so one of the I guess the
issues that we need to understand is I
understand the experience in the
industry may make you an ideal candidate
for a
um to be a franchisee however we're not
nothing's going to be guaranteed here
what I'm trying to explain to you is if
you're going to join the retail
Market
I think having we got to keep it fair
for the other
franchisees that's that's the problem it
goes both ways you guys already are
operating a
your therapeutic centers now so I I'm
trying to kind of merge those into one
not having an exception for here an
exception for there it's get confusing
going from store to store especially
when you
have enforcement on one end not involved
in that not involved in some of the rul
making process it seems to be a lot of
different angles Now by combining them
and I'm just saying if every store was
on equal footing with that I think
that's beneficial to patients where I
live in Salem where's the closest
therapeutic location marac am I am I
correct when I say that that that's a
pretty long drive if there's a retail
store in sale them they're going to just
most people are just going to go there
to buy right we see that most of our
customers are centered right around the
atc's so while patients are registered
throughout the state most most of the
actual people that visit our stores
actually live fairly close on average um
and I think that's representative of a
lack of access throughout the state to
the medical program so potentially by
allowing any franchise to do
that this to be able to sell a
therapeutic product that would maybe
increase the amount of members in that
program but
if the franchise or needs to be on board
with that and that's why I'm trying to
kind of put the therapeutic program
under liquor is that if they're going to
ow that type of partnership with
their with their franchises I feel like
they want they're going to want to have
more involvement in the process that's
no disrespect to DHHS I'm just saying
I'm just looking at from a business
perspective why would they want to have
that Partnership if they have no real
control over what's happening there does
that make sense they don't have a hand
on the wheel but then their entire model
is resting on it so I don't I don't see
another way to practically do it do it m
turn away so obviously this is a big
topic um we probably need to continue to
next meeting and make sure we have this
conversation but as I understand it
again I'm trying to think of in a
regulatory model which pieces would fall
under liquor and which pieces would stay
with DHHS I mean operationally it makes
sense that a given physical location is
regulated by a single entity so makes
sense that liquor controls marketing and
and and messaging and some of that that
happens with a given entity for a store
however I could also see where when it
comes to the manufacturing side um there
might be some dhh input as to potency
and and requirements for the therapeutic
grade products that would be offered in
those stores but I don't think it's a
stretch to say that a single retail
store could have both the and this is a
change for me so because I was a I was
really a dual store I guy but I'm now
falling underneath the idea of a a
unistore a single store model um that
allows for the sale of the medicinal
product the therapeutic product um in
the in the retail store provided that a
the medicinal product is regulated for
therapeutic purposes which means the
manufacturing side has to fall under
DHHS and what what are allowed limits
and the retail side of the store is
governed but the physical location
operations component has to be regul by
a single entity that's my concern so I I
think it belongs in liquor for the
operational aspect of this product um
technology-wise it's no big deal
depending on what we decide on taxation
whether a therapeutic product is is
continued part of the gross and subject
to the 15% or not considered part of the
gross that's a checkbox and a point of
sales system that's not hard to do um we
do it right now in in our ret in our
restaurants there are some products that
are tax and some products that aren't
tax in a restaurant and they're able to
identify that within their Point of
Sales system so that's not probably itic
but I just say I think bigger topic we
probably need to continue this at
another meeting with that understanding
and maybe someone putting together an
outline of what they propos for those
that want to keep their putic stores
completely separated should probably
present what that looks like as it
relates to retail and those that want to
commingle retail and um and and
therapeutic in the same store what that
model looks like where's the bifurcation
happen regulations um as it lays out
it's probably be a best way for us to
understand how this
looks and just to clarify the point I
was making too you would need to have a
if there's a therapeutic thade product
you still need a therapeutic card I
think that's where thhs would still
provide the most value is when it comes
to issuing the card I think that's
that's important but when it comes to
the rest of the enforceability side
that's where I shift it
over yeah I mean you know you you go to
CVS you have uh over the count drugs and
not overthe counter drugs in the same
store um and they're still governed by
the
FDA um I think it totally makes sense to
have um The Liquor Commission oversee
all all of this stuff and we definitely
have the ability to do it and I think by
reassigning it there's a lot of
knowledge that would be reassigned you
know would help lior in you know getting
this program up and running they' be
able to I might use the word Consulting
but they they bring some industry
knowledge internally that would be
helpful too
this was jarif I can on one other
different topic we move on from this one
just real I just want to close the loop
Frank did his homework assignment he
broaden the definition of Resident
everyone has it in front of you um on
page five we have a definition in there
that's different than the definition in
statute my recommendation is just to
strike this what's in the bill for a
definition and knowing that under the
the chapter 21 statutory construction 21
colon 6 has a definition and in all
instances where it's not defined
specifically it'll refer back to this
anyway so I think we can just strike
residents from the definition section I
would
agree or refer to page five well I was
going to refer to but again by default
it does it automatically so so just
strike section 24 on page five where we
have a definition of resident and know
that we already have a statutory
definition of what a resident is under
6 we're making the bill shorter inter
read our next
meeting it's a good
question I I did uh have is the next
meeting the 16th sorry I think so no I
was just gonna say I do for the next
meeting we reached out to the treasurer
because there's a request of having a
Treasurer come on to speak um and
they're weren't available for today but
they will be available for the next one
which I think is the 16th give me one
second and I won't be here so we have
the 16th what's our
other yeah 16th is the next meeting and
after the 16th what's our next one I
don't have the next one I don't have in
front of
me so we only have two meetings left um
we have we have 12 17 Pages still to get
through all right
so you I will be here on the 16th what
if we move the 16th to the 17th did that
work for anyone not for
me going back to an I have I have I I
got to go to Pittsburg on the 16th in
the afternoon so I can be here in the
morning for the 16th but 17th 17 I'm the
date that works for at what time we back
it up the 15th I can't be here in the
15th that's the one I could
be you you do the 17th I'm I'm going out
of state on the 16th to a tax
um my other hat tax guy I got a instant
to so so 16th is the day we have to
stick with all right I I would well
light well it's you know we have to have
a quum that's the
problem so if we do the six 16 maybe we
got to be prepared to be here for a full
day after to we'll take a lunch break is
everyone would maybe be prepared for a
morning and and afternoon on the 16th
yes okay well I just let you know my
flight out of Logan is at
uh five o'clock 201 16th yeah M mine's
at 2:30 250 so I can stay a little later
I can stay a little later but I'm just
chair is there is there any way we could
start an hour
earlier we certainly can on the 16th
yeah I might be late myself but that's
all
right if we start early I can be on the
16th and do the first half of the
morning I just got to be out of here by
noonish so we get you guys can we start
9:30 or 9
9 I may I yes I just think there
there besides scheduling there's a sort
of larger point that I don't think going
line by line is going to get us we're
not going to have time to do that and so
maybe the chair wants to consider a
process that would be more efficient to
get us to where we need to be um that's
how I'm feeling at this point well I
think I think if we're supposed to
recommend legislation I think come
coming to a somewhat of a consensus
we're not going to agree on every
division but putting something out there
as kind of
a I guess the working draft a lot of the
provisions we kind of went line by line
with and whether I agree with it or
someone else we kind of just been doing
a kind of a rough vote on it and the
majority has been kind of owning the day
on so some of the provisions have been
taken out put
in a lot of it's been done that way most
of the stuff we agreed on some of stuff
I just think there's a lot of actually
open questions I I think yeah we're
going to agree on most but I think the
big issues we haven't agreed on and so
um I think maybe having some more
structured conversation to get to a
consensus on those points of
disagreement might might be more
more structure structured conversation
about those areas where we don't this
and what are those topics yeah I think
that we can identify those absolutely I
think that we're still kind of The
Possession limit still up up in the air
I think not to open that can right now
but if we pride ourselves on out State
consumers I think people buy in bulk
it's what it is if you live right next
near the store I don't see why you buy
invol but I think we got to balance that
with the public safety side of things so
we were still haven't agreed on the
public use provision so I we just left
it as the violation for now I think in
the the hearings in the the legislative
bodies that might have to be had out
because we couldn't come to a consensus
on anything with that I think we're
waiting on the on the nanogram
measurement to see if there's any way to
kind of ballpark what would be
appropriate with that seems that it's
been somewhat arbitrarily applied in
other states but we we don't want
inadvertent violators of that so we have
that to work on but you know that's
still
undecided and then there's the issue of
whether we'll have dual
licenses or we're going to have separate
you know if they're GNA be if the atc's
join the retail Market there no one's
stopping them from doing
it um whether we're going to allow two
signs in these dual stores
and the potential problems that
creates I think that's that's those are
the only points of contention right
anything I think the Zone we haven't got
to zoning yet but I know that's
gonna I think it says 200 feet some we
there anything
else any points of contention
any all right I think I think A J so
just to clarify 9:30 on on the 16th or 9
N nine o'clock on on this on the 16th
but I would just advise everyone I know
not all of us can stay but we should be
prepared to stay at maybe at least two
or three
o'clock and hopefully give folks lunch
break in a lunch with a lunch break yes
yeah and uh that that is Jael cards yeah
I already told him I was going to make
the meeting be
here start laying with cater I hope I'll
be here in morning as long as you come
back by hearing any any other any other
questions from the members of the
rej
that